I have been making bone broth for almost six years,
and historically, I've always cooked it from 24 to 48 hours.
Until last year. New research had come out
showing bone broth is higher in histamines than, say,
a meat stock. Undesirable effects like headaches can happen.
So does that mean that you shouldn't consume bone broth
and should just do a meat stock?
It's really hard to deny the benefits of bone broth.
Bone broth being higher in L glutamine,
which is an amino acid
that is absolutely necessary for the repair of a damaged gut lining.
Also much higher in things like collagen and gelatin.
Because of all the connective tissue.
I always make sure to have a lot of meat on my bones.
Instead of switching over to a meat stock,
I am actually just simmering my bone broth for less time.
So instead of doing 24 to 48 hours,
I'm doing about 8 to 12 hours.
And that way the histamine content is much lower.